greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by blue apron blue apron delivers
farm-fresh ingredients and step-by-step
recipes right to your door
blue aprons mission is to make
incredible home cooking accessible to
everybody now blue apron achieves us by
supporting a more sustainable food
system setting the highest standards for
ingredients and building a community of
home chefs how it works very simple you
choose chef design recipes we deliver
fresh seasonal inspired ingredients and
you can cook an incredible meal in as
little as twenty minutes I'm gonna do
this for you check out this week's menu
and get your first three meals free
that's listen free at blue apron Tom's
last Joey that's blue apron coms last
Joey get your first meal for free right
now go to blue apron com slash Joey
listen also the church is brought to you
by you ready for this one 23andme
23andme is named for the 23 pairs of
chromosomes that make up our DNA 23andme
is a personal genetic service that helps
you understand what your DNA can tell
you about you and your loved ones and
your family's story as your loved ones
get together this Thanksgiving I'll tell
you what I'm going to do discover more
about you genetic connections you share
do you inherit your blue eyes from your
grandmother or do you get your blonde
hair from yours your dad how much of
your DNA is compared to your brother or
your sisters see how your DNA breaks out
across 150 regions worldwide what I'm
going to do is this
now today through Thanksgiving 23andme
ancestry service kits are only $49 per
kid did you hear me what I'm saying it's
$49 per kid they're usually a hundred
dollars but for the holidays will give
me a 50% off when you buy two or more
kits this is a Christmas present you and
the wife you and your step kid you and
your net whatever it is this
your chance to find out who you really
are what really makes you tick all right
that's 50% off your regular kit price at
$99 this holiday
order your 23andme ancestry service kit
at 23andme Tom's last Church again
that's 23andme dot-com slash church the
church is also brought to you by washi
asses [ __ ] it's a holiday season
Toshi calm Toshi calm is a portable
demon a portable bidet that's what I'm
talking about here right now I smoked a
couple numbers don't worry about nothing
it's a portable bidet takes you seven
minutes to install it and there you are
no more toilet paper you're helping the
world
you're helping the globe hey listen talk
is cheap you even want to stink yeah so
you want to clean [ __ ] it's up to you
Toshi calm is there to help you right
now you get 10% off any touching
portable bidet portable bidet for as
little as $69 all right as little as $69
listen go to Toshi comm codeword muffler
and get 10% off any portable bidet they
got in stock all right and they start as
low as $69 different colors hot water
all that stuff go to two she calmly kick
that [ __ ] mule and that's it
it's about Brody Stephens yes we are
here feeling good relaxed in the moment
I'm comfortable I've been on the show
good to see you guys leave and Joey
always great to bump into you you know I
was thinking about who I have on this
time I said [ __ ] Brody Stevens I just
saw him at the stolen me get my [ __ ]
arm oh yeah it was yeah I saw you at the
store showing my face see how you doing
call me what time you spots usually I
get normally I'll do Friday or Saturday
in the main room closing it out which is
like 12:30 12:45 late and then
occasionally I'll get an earlier spot in
the original room like at 10:45 or an 11
so Adam the Booker and they mix it up
for me but I get two to three spots a
week but I make the most
those if I get those main room spots I
and I go up at the end that's I get to
spread my wings and do my own thing and
that's what I made my special based on
doing those late-night main room spots
or I'm just kind of letting it go so I
still do those I've kind of you know
I've done it already so I'm looking to
do something more but getting some
motivation for you know but they switch
it up but you got to hustle got a plate
Laugh Factory
got to go The Improv got to do these
other shows got to show your face listen
the hustle never ends
like I said Sebastian Maniscalco so
lunch four shows at Madison Square
Garden and I'm telling you every day and
all of a struggle whatever level you're
at comically you know stat whatever
right every day you got to get up and
face and it work and [ __ ] you know
whatever it is that you do to get you
know closer to your goal whatever the
[ __ ] it is you know it was interesting
you were talking about the beginning of
the show that you'd done with the meds
you done well I have been for how long
four months how do you feel good I mean
my mood is low I feel like I have to
build up my rewire my brain a little bit
and my body I think that it takes
several months to like get it out of
your system and then you get used to
being different but essentially I feel
like my old self but that doesn't
necessarily you know and I only had I
had a year to in New York when I was not
really on anything but being here in Los
Angeles since 2000
I think yet the pressures maybe of the
Internet
made me and all these so many more
things happening but initially I started
taking it in Seattle because I get up
there and do comedy and it would I
wouldn't feel right I wouldn't
I felt like Oh Brody you're funny you're
funny playing baseball then when I went
up there and did comedy it was it was
rough so I I did take something to help
me have the edge taken off however I
feel like 20 years now later
to say your honor only on a med because
it helps your comedy is kind of like a
weak excuse well listen before by the
way it's I think it's I called it just
to stay safe
I always said it was November 15th but
it was more like the 8th or the 9th when
I gave up cocaine this is 11 years 11
years hopefully this week
congratulations
11 [ __ ] years coke free something
that I never ever ever thought I could
live with that
mm-hmm like something that I thought but
if I got off it I wouldn't be funny that
was my biggest fear of getting off the
cocaine was that I would lose my sense
of humor yeah so when you said that
before the show started I assured you
that that does not happen you know being
I don't know history was with meds and I
didn't want to put it on the front
street but you put it on the upholstery
well and you know what then there's a
lot of people who listen to this show
but are on meds and maybe it's maybe you
inspire them to maybe go you know what
I'm gonna give myself a chance I'm gonna
travel in my life I'm gonna try to get a
good control good what do you call that
around you know good support support
system showing your face being important
the support system around you is the
most important thing you know I took
Kate Quigley to the New York Comedy
Festival mm-hmm and Wednesday night I
had all my friends me to the Chinese
restaurant and we all wait and little by
little kept she kept saying my friends
and she goes I understand you and now a
lot more you know you've kept in touch
with these people for 40 [ __ ] years
mm-hmm and they support you and you know
instead of me going out and buying a BMW
and getting an assistant I call one of
them every day and I hear them telling
me how they have to call me back because
they deliver in a package from Federal
Express and they tell me how they have
to drive home at 8:00 but go back to
work at 10:00 because a ship is coming
in and they gotta count stuff so when I
talk to them every day it keeps me
grounded
it says to me [ __ ] they're 55 and I have
a friend who delivers he's 56 that's my
brother and he delivers [ __ ] packages
all day for Federal Express I would give
up if you think I could deliver packages
travel Express today
you better [ __ ] shoot yourself either
climb up stairs all day and drop off
boxes that's not gonna happen I would
quit the middle of the day
depends on what city any city I think I
wouldn't have I don't have it in me to
deliver packages all day right now there
is no [ __ ] way even if I was 50
pounds lighter a hundred pounds lighter
there is no way at 55 so I could be
walking up and down stairs I know
there's plenty of men that are doing it
the Amazon guys I'm sure what I speak to
these guys that I grew up with mm-hmm
you know what my one friend says he raps
on the weekends to make us an extra 200
hours a week so that's family
so during baseball season he goes up on
stage you know he goes up on stage I'm
sorry he [ __ ] goes to a Little League
field at 8:00 in the morning and he's
dead at 6:00 at night on Saturdays and
Sundays after he delivers fell Express
all [ __ ] week
oh the same guy same guys okay 175 hours
for the day so his family could have an
extra 1400 a month and I'm Mike bitching
about you having a gig for 400 bucks
waiting I'm saying right when I talked
to him he keeps my life in perspective
it keeps me in check I don't want to be
surrounded with people who look at life
or like a value I want it always always
you know
so that's who keeps me grounded that's
my support group those little [ __ ]
friends I call in the morning
and just how I break your balls and
break their balls I know when they're
busy and then when they're busiest and I
call them then I call them again these
are friends back in back east are all
over although just saying hello saying
hello because it keeps you [ __ ]
ground I talked to Bob Levine yesterday
I'm a listener from the podcast you know
Tom I gotta call Bobby Sharon every day
is somebody
you know and these people keep you
humble is it also just socializing
keeping those I love my friends injury
yeah I love him more every time I see
him I see him for ten minutes and it
means the world to them and it means the
world to me
mm-hmm Hey when I'm home I go to
breakfast at this one I go to see my
mother's cemetery with that one this one
takes me to get Cuban food this one
takes me Rudy's this one drives me to
chance so I have a different
relationship with all of one and I talk
to them you know I have a friend who 55
went to MIT Massachusetts Institute of
Technology the one in New York the other
New Jersey one I think one where people
will [ __ ] geniuses you know what he
does when he delivers bread from
midnight to 11:00 in the morning for 200
hauls a ship move he makes a thousand
bucks a week and sometimes you work
Saturday nights all night delivering
bread in the village but he's got to
work from 6:00 in the morning with all
that traffic he's got to get over to the
Jersey side and I wouldn't [ __ ] want
to do that at all at my age again so all
these guys keep me grounded
so whatever keeps you grounded from the
evil in your mind coming out or whatever
the [ __ ] happens to all of us that's the
most important thing I'm telling you
this is a 55 year old like I'm an old
[ __ ] man and I wish I knew this when
I was 30 yeah that you have to have
three people four people and you breathe
for them and they breathe for you no
questions asked yeah I have friends I
need to I'm from here it's a little
different that's an excuse though like
my best I know my best from one of my
close friends I still like lives up near
Magic Mountain I should probably call
maybe tomorrow I'll call up quality I'll
call them take them to lunch I just
having done it make a deal with him that
you were gonna make sure and meet him
every two weeks for lunch I need to have
the same diner to eat the same bowl of
soup whether it's a Jewish what if I
have an audition good for [ __ ] that's
the problem
that's the problem that we forget who we
are because we have the audition I had a
commitment with you every Sunday at 11
o'clock you have to make that commitment
tomorrow you know pisses me off tomorrow
and today was my heavy day so today I
lifted it done with the kickboxing
tomorrow I don't know how I'm gonna wake
up on my back gonna feel if I miss
jiu-jitsu I feel guilty because I had a
date with jiu-jitsu well I get a [ __ ]
call for an audition on the Tuesday have
one I get past cuz I gotta miss jujitsu
right when I got a call for a [ __ ]
meeting to meet somebody at 2 o'clock
and the Hollywood that means I can't go
to judge it so I gonna do the
conditioning and then I get [ __ ]
pissed you know I don't want nothing to
interfere whatever keeps me grounded and
I wish that I had known this when I
first moved to LA and I didn't have a
grounding I had people like Ralphie May
and yourself and Josh wolves and
whatever but nobody protected me from
myself which nobody could ever do
nobody could protect you from being you
it takes you to protect yourself I know
right how hard is that it's hard it's
hard you know it's that's why you need
you know having family having a wife or
a husband or a dog or something or it's
you gotta have you have to bill if you
don't have that you got to build up your
support system you got a it just takes
effort it takes effort and you want it
and be a good person I think but also
getting out of the house it's just with
the internet these days
social media it does affect people well
how long have you lived alone Brody
probably now for great questionably
probably now for six years because like
I lived alone for eight years someone
like that and even this weekend I was
like some things happen that right no
way I mean I was just getting into my
head mm-hmm and I didn't I talked to a
few people but I don't most of the damn
by myself and even just as terrible as I
sounded I was just driving I just was
thinking about what's going on with a
fight
it sounds like you know what this is
that really doesn't matter like what I'm
going through is in the grand scheme of
things I'm Jude I'm making a worse in my
head so I think it's hard sometimes as a
person who lives alone to like get out
of their head well yeah I mean that's
why I well one I go for walks actually
getting out and then I do that periscope
I do talk I mean I'm not hearing their
voices but I am doing these check-ins I
am connecting with my community there is
something true to having a your audience
your fans they do mean something so I do
lean on them some sometimes more than
others so you know that having a
roommate I had a roommate back my old my
last apartment and he was a really good
roommate they're hard to come by
but I think yes being social and when
you are living alone and you're its it
could be your gonna like make it happen
but when you if you like I said look you
called me today Joey I didn't know you
know this was not like something that
was booked it was energy I feel like you
got to be in it to win it
that's half the battle so and not
feeling sorry for yourself but I think
having a roommate you think that would
be better like no I could trust me I I
haven't had a remains in it's college
and that's oh really
yeah it's it but I I have sacrificed
financially for it I could have saved a
lot of money by getting a roommate or
even if I was spending the same amount
of money getting a bigger place but I
live with someone for a year and even he
would say when I did it that it's like
I'm a bear I'm a very much introverted
person yeah and it takes a special kind
I can't live with that many people okay
I like my space I like I like to go
somewhere and have no one like to unplug
like want something that's been kind of
a struggle for me that I have to work on
is hanging out after comedy sets I don't
feel comfortable really hanging out
after yeah after the show
yeah so yeah and what talking to the
other comedians talking to the fans well
the audience members I mean the people
you know the people who come
a little bit different it's quicker
conversations I can ask them about can
talk be like hey what are you doing
listen that but and I have some friends
I do open mics with now right but uh I
don't unless it's a few people like two
or three people I could hang around for
an hour if it's seven or eight people
I'll hang around for like 20 minutes so
you just want to get out of there yeah I
just want to go home
and you feel like that's not good yeah I
think I need to be a little bit more so
I mean I'm more social already but I
think it would be beneficial if I was
you know hanging out yeah I don't know
people and a more personal basis I mean
that's why the comedy store so popular
yeah I'm gonna hang out you hang out
there right you come by there a little
bit yeah and I'm gonna I've been I just
have to force myself to to stay and and
do I I haven't ever done that like twice
in the past week but one of the times I
had a show so it didn't really I didn't
really count it as just hanging help but
you set up you go like on uh you know
whatever night once or I have to start
doing that more I've been avoiding it
yeah because everybody's hanging out
there they're all similar same likes and
you know you're at the Comedy Store
right and then you're gonna meet other
comedians you're gonna meet fans you're
gonna be around people all that stuff I
mean that's why i go i I go I know I
have a place I do the same thing yeah I
do the same thing I forced myself to go
to store but let's back this
conversation up because these are some
interesting [ __ ] things that are
happening okay just now Lee and I when
we first started doing the podcast we
started at my apartment had an extra
bedroom and then this is not I'm not
hating on Lee people we knows I'm about
to tell you people and then we got an
apartment and it was a two-bedroom and
we do the bed podcasts out of his
apartment
mhm and I love Lee Lia's come upon my
home Lee that was my family Lee could
come to my home whenever he wants he
knows that yeah I know from doing the
podcast that year and Lee's apartment
and how he acted that I have never been
back to one of these apartment not
because he's a bad person he's always
hosted me he always had diet cokes for
me his apartment was clean okay okay
I just know Lee I know for me being Who
I am that leave there's people who want
you at their house
there's people who love open up the door
come in come in sit down take your shoes
off put your feet on the table look at
there's people who were Naturals at that
yeah there's people who are [ __ ]
Naturals at that they want to entertain
I wish I could be one of those people
okay so one just that relationship of me
going to Lee's home in the mornings you
knew his podcast and at one time there
was a girl sleeping on his couch oh I
could see that the effect of when that
girl moved out on Lee and I tried to
tell him not because I'm a hater before
Lee told me he was gonna let his
girlfriend move in and only from a
standpoint of a [ __ ] old man that
reads people and is a loner remember
guys I was alone it you put me in my
room by myself as a kid I was alone I
was a lonely child Louis I got a [ __ ]
record player and the TV but something
happened to me in 1987 that 1986
something interesting happened to me and
I'll admit this on the air right now and
it's called something but it affected me
in a different way it's called cabin
fever
okay the same thing that happened to it
yeah so the guy in the shining well yeah
okay so what happened is in Aspen the
spring of 86 my my girlfriend who became
my wife said it's the off season
everybody loses their job so instead of
sitting all the restaurants closed right
now everything closes I mean it goes
from being aa heavy-duty [ __ ] people
jumping off cliffs with bikinis on 2
April 15
nothing like nothing like from traffic
just six cars and you know that stays
open as a supermarket at least is this I
wasn't 86 all that would stay openly was
a supermarket for limited hours cuz all
that was left was the residents of that
town
people who working slowly instead of
their being nine bars now there was a
hotel with one bar open and that's the
way it was till mid June
then the bicycle races came and the hot
air balloons came and then it became
people come back up yeah but this is six
weeks family that I had to work three
hours a day some days just to open up
the video store and I could look at you
guys in the face and tell you that there
were days I wouldn't even open the door
the door then this is no drugs this is
me smoking pop pop in video after video
in the movies video after video not
watching movies yeah pissing and
[ __ ] in between eating something in
between making a shade yeah I did that
you could do that back then I did that
for six weeks
well it's like a film festival a had
been really weird because before that I
lived in New York and I had a hostel and
I was out of the house every day my
block stealing selling drugs yep
stealing [ __ ] tampons and sell them
on the New York side to bodegas up on
the in Washington Heights I was just a
friend you know and those six weeks
affected me I started to twist a little
bit I started to get bad thoughts not
suicidal you know coming back and
murdering my stepdad and just [ __ ]
dumb stuff so from those six weeks I
learned one thing from my personal
mental health it was always good for me
get up a cup of coffee you know go to
your balcony hit you joint twice you
have that your head together
yep write out a plan for your day what
you want to accomplish for the day like
in written form in the paragraph so they
I feel great I got eight hours to sleep
ba ba ba ba and take a shower we get out
of the house even if you have nowhere to
go and make your bed actually it's so
healthy for you but if you look at the
questionnaire for depression its
it starts with that being alone and not
getting your hand forced mm-hmm you know
I'm not crying but you getting your hand
for us to do something a lot of people
don't like their hand for it when you
say hand forced if you get a roommate
you can't do what you usually do act
like a [ __ ] gavone and just on the
couch all day and watch videos okay now
you have a roommate Lea made the point
that he's been living alone but if he
had a roommate maybe he get our house
more I believe in getting out of the
[ __ ] house I think it's I think the
son has amazing powers I think the air
has amazing power you know there's some
days I'm feeling a ho-hum I know exactly
what it is I haven't jumped in the
shower it it's it's proven walking is
beneficial for you for your brain for
your BA house or everything so there's
no the only thing somebody would say
about walking you should be doing more
you should be then turn it into a hike
the bottom line is walking helps anybody
you know if it's helping you and
especially as a performer you know
mental met just met Slade I go out and I
walk and a lot of the creative ideas
come from when people walk I do my
periscope so I'm walking and I check in
with people and then luckily we're here
in Southern California we and we have
that sunlight so I do you know at least
I'm doing that I always say like I'm not
a couch potato I'm checking in even if
I'm doing another periscope and I'm
playing drums I'm sitting on a Swiss
ball I'm exercising so I'm trying to at
least you know show people like being
active and if I don't do a periscope or
you know I don't do an Instagram video
people are gonna go hey Brody what's up
so they kind of it's it still doesn't
beat having an actual physical person
with you it's a little bit of an AI
think when you when you have
relationships with your audience members
that you actually don't even hear their
voices so you do need that human
interaction and part of it is having
guests on a podcast I've been to I got
to the point where I wasn't even booking
guests on podcast there's just me and
you know the mic and the camera it's
like I need to be
people so I've made a concerted effort I
think the last couple months or so is
like be social put the put the effort
out and yet get out of your head just so
and I see results I got at least try I
mean listen you and I like it you have
to be in your head to be self-conscious
but I don't want you to be this
self-conscious that you destroy yourself
from 79 to 85 walking was my
psychiatrist walking with and without an
iPad pad on whatever would you call
those a wall command Walkman discman
well I walked miles and that was my
psychiatry mmm-hmm we just walked walk
walk
get your steps up walk walk I didn't do
it for health reasons it was to
psychiatry I had I had a breakdown what
had just happened in my life and how was
gonna make my future better mm-hmm and
it would be smoking a joint and walking
from Cliffside Park the [ __ ]
Englewood and back six miles or
something a retardation just wasting
time mm-hmm I was free what's that
called procrastinating yeah that's what
I thought was also breaking it down what
had just happened and I was breaking
down my next attack and I finally had
the balls and it took me and I launched
in 85 that was my attack but that was a
year of walking so you were walking
before you were doing stand-up
what stand-up wasn't even in my future
okay Prison was in my future at that
gotcha
and I was a walker walking away like if
I lived here I would walk towards
[ __ ] you know Sunland mm-hmm everyday
you know on a slant with a knife I would
force myself to walk by myself
no cell phone in your pocket no calls
and break down what had just happened in
my life the death of my mother how I was
gonna survive wasn't gonna go to
vocational school was I gonna go to
college was gonna get my GED how was it
you know it was just a constant walking
was my psychiatrist you know today I got
up this morning early there was no
school so me and my wife had a shared
duties
so I got up this morning and I wonder
early what television but then at 9:00 I
went and went to my Muay Thai little
conditioning class mm-hmm
what happened before I walked him I got
to the quarter mile I just did that
about my car before minutes and I just
soaked in the Sun mm-hmm bye Manny and
naturally I said to myself just being
outside is helping me mm-hmm
you know I always tell people you could
take private lessons or you could be in
a class Senate I'd much rather be in the
class setting so I have relationships
with different people in that class
because I'm the type of guy that I can
get up at eight kotemari ET and sit
there riding to one and then go home go
to your office and on social media for
an hour return emails hmm and then talk
to my wife talk to my kid and I could
stay home mm-hmm and I could do that for
three or four nights in a row and that
sucks death that makes me go crazy it's
one reason why I call them for spots at
the comedy stores to force me to get off
my ass and go down there cuz you can't
cancel
no so you have to go down there when I'm
driving back from the comedy store I
feel so satisfied at the end of that but
I accomplished my mission for the day
even if you have a bad set even if every
bad so it's not about bad sex or guy
like me it's about the same two things
you guys are talking about human contact
yeah yeah I mean that's that's one thing
god you need it we're human beings I'm
talking about as soon as you wake up I
want you to give yourself an hour for
you I want you to take that hour I
always think when I get up in the
morning I thank the Lord that he gave me
another day and I thank the Lord that I
didn't grow up I'm not growing up in the
house we're at 6:30 in the morning
a bomb gets dropped in your house Lee's
getting shaved I gotta wait for him we
can't use the bathroom because Brody
took a [ __ ] it smells like [ __ ] ten
people died
yeah yeah I'm washing machine broke so
the [ __ ] your shirts not ready no now
you got a high on it by hand everybody's
getting up in a bad mood and now you
gotta get on a train a bad mood never be
late to work I [ __ ] hated that [ __ ]
we don't watch that did not fly my world
I know I needed to get up I need a
little break in the morning I put music
on I get coffee I sit there with a
notebook that's wide open I put Tuesday
November 13th on it and I say it's a
beautiful day from to be alive and from
there I just let and I don't stop till
the end of the page so your journal
that's not journal in the morning to get
the waste out today I'm gonna do this
just this list I [ __ ] don't want to
do it because the 405 is gonna have
traffic on it and when I talked myself
out of everything I could talk myself
out of so it's all over after that page
my day is decided you know what I was
gonna do what's his name his podcast I'm
not driving to Marina del Rey I'm
texting him at nine o'clock and telling
them you're in no danger you know that's
when I decided that how I feel if I wake
up on my back hurts and I can't move
then I'm not gonna go to do two at 12:00
let's make alternate plans who's got a
podcast you got a podcast yet when do
you do it once it won't let's do it
tomorrow at 12:00 that's how I work
because I don't want it skipped I don't
know what I'm be available but it's
about also you know scheduling stuff
scheduling stuff and always keeping
yourself busy this business what we do
let me tell you something and I'm not
going to do this that none of you people
anymore
because I know sometimes and comedians
can bond here [ __ ] in today's world
it gets crazy if you get caught up in
today's world between the internet oh
yeah the media
oh yeah and what's going on you were
gonna go crazy
yep I'm not gonna mention no names cuz
I'm my hair embarrassed of it but I
think we have discussed that we've seen
a couple people lose their minds within
the last two or three years oh yeah on
the internet on the internet in public
we've seen we've heard of people losing
their minds
there's too much information getting
poured into the human life
yeah yep so right now you have to learn
how to control that - you have to learn
how to control that - and decide on what
level how much of this are you gonna
take in you know what I'm listening to
11 podcast a week that's 33 hours
I gotta chop it down to five you do you
know what I'm watching too much [ __ ]
football
I gotta chop it down or just Sundays
no more Thursday game I'm gonna take the
ship the [ __ ] Chili's isn't as I cook
you know I'm saying like I'm gonna take
an extra shift you have to control what
gets put into your mind right now
because of what's going on in the world
what ABC News is feeding you and when
the internet is feeding you it really
really is overwhelming for the mind yeah
I well I don't look at the you know the
ABC news really I'll glance at those
guys but I listen - all right listen to
KFI local radio here in LA but I go on
the internet for my news and it's it's I
mean it's a battle out there to be
honest with you how it is and I wake up
every morning and a lot of times to be
honest I'm up in the morning I'm looking
at that internet I'm looking at that
Twitter and I'm look I'm trying to find
things and I I do my sets at the Comedy
Store I come home I go straight to
Twitter and I'm not on there like get in
fights of people I'm just researching
stuff I'm researching stuff and I feel
like I'm ahead of the head of the game
on on what's happening and I feel like
the last few years with with the
politics the way they are it has kind of
taken taken pulled me into an area at
least my energy not necessarily I'm not
getting into fights on the internet I'm
not that guy but it does get your blood
boiling a little bit but I do avoid it
but I also I'm digging in oh I want I
want I wanna stay I want everybody to be
happy I want to do whatever it takes to
get it back to where we're happy and
working together and that's what I'm
pulled in there too and it takes
takes your time and I feel like I'm not
a part of that mob mentality I'm a
little I'm a little different on
blue-collar I'm from the valley grew up
you know and it bothers me what I don't
like seeing comedian friends of mine
angry on Twitter so I do not I try not
to not try to block it and not see it
but it's a bummer for me and so that can
get to you I feel it's a tough time to
be a human being right now it's I feel
mentally if you get sucked in it's a
tough time to be a human being right now
you have to know your yang and your Yin
and your boarders you know you have to
make time for yourself you have to take
care of yourself yes you have to you
know you're talking to a guy that lived
in his head for years and it got me
nowhere it got me nowhere so I expressed
what was in my head that's where I
started getting places you know we
overthink things and in the process of
thinking we think ourselves out of the
game right let me think about you get
the idea
you got a piece of paper you write it
out and you go to work
so you weren't you weren't journaling
during the years you're in your head
not even thinking about it
there was no journaling there was
nothing there was no journaling in my
life till 1994 the nice to meet inner
knowing my calmly stuff that's a nice
pen then I went to Seattle and there was
a skinny woman that was a comic that
wasn't that funny old or married then
one day she turned me on to a book
called the writer's way or something and
she told me I could borrow it for a few
days and I read it and then there
already I was doing it and there a
recommended excuse
but when you wake up in the morning you
should get a fresh piece of paper and
express your thoughts for the day and I
was like I'm on to something if that
time in you is at this time this was the
hot book you know the book right the
writers way or there was a gene for a
no-no wasn't it wasn't probably right
okay writing and how self-help
journaling this is I learned that in
college Arizona State I never know about
journaling to comedy Adam lice get
caught up I would journal at night you
know like tell him myself this is the
last time I'm gonna do it I have to stop
this life even though I get set tonight
I'm making good moves in my life am I
still writing doing coke I think
journaling is the best thing in the
world for you I think journaling is the
best psychiatry I think every Friday
every Saturday morning I wake up and I
had we thought I read but I read for the
week I read what I wrote mmm from Monday
on number one everything that I write in
that journal in the mornings gets done
plus I have another notebook that has my
schedule plus you have a calendar that
has my schedule and you know I have
three things to know my schedule one is
my day step by step nine o'clock eleven
o'clock twelve thirty four o'clock 5:30
eight o'clock podcast ten o'clock spot
at The Comedy Store and then there's the
journal part of it right it's just a
yellow notebook and every day I wake up
when I write backwards to front so I
start back and I write to the front
that'll start in the front I started the
back and white at the front just
superstitious I don't want to write like
everybody else I was starting to back
and I write to the front and it opens up
with Monday November 13th first line is
always just a beautiful day to be alive
that's the first thought that she's
coming to add I don't give a [ __ ] if
you're in the ditch and there's a rock
on top of you as long as you're
breathing if you say that to yourself
your day is gonna be completely [ __ ]
it's been proven it's been proven people
pray the limits go up you're not
supposed to pray they say though the
auxin prayers you're not supposed to
pray but saying that to yourself it's a
beautiful day to be Oh God why are you
pissing why are you pissing all that
piss is coming out here and your knee
hurts and your neck is stiff or mean
[ __ ] and that blister under your tongue
from eating [ __ ] and ass it can happen
and the chase Noctem idiot it still
doesn't matter why you're peeing if you
say to yourself it's a beautiful day to
be alive
whatever [ __ ] comes into your mind on
top of that it's not gonna matter I
gotta go to court today I'm broke I'm
hungry I don't have money to pay rent if
you say that to yourself first
it's beautiful that every journal mine
starts like that right Thursday November
16th it's a [ __ ] beautiful [ __ ]
day to be alive today I gotta do this I
gotta do this I gotta go see this
[ __ ] scumbag I gotta go deal with
this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
and whatever I gotta pick the baby up at
4:00 but hey you know what twenty years
ago I was [ __ ] trying to stand some
money look where I am today at least I
am living and breathing I'm healthy I
got my house you know it's just that
part of it yeah well that's why I like
working on a TV show every day or
working with maybe with the baseball
team you bring that energy and yes we're
here push they people like that they
like that energy bringing it lifting
people up positive self-talk you have to
do it because it does work I know it
sounds silly but it does work to put
that you're putting that energy out it
really is an energy of you're putting it
out it does I'm not saying it comes back
to you
but you do put it out and people like
being around it that's the thing people
like being around that that's you know
it's a motive it's like a coach it's
motivational upbeat it can be done and
you can kind of train yourself I would
think at least to believe that it works
you know it's not easy to do but if you
believe it you know what's there and
that's what I and I
that from I learned in at Arizona State
about the power of the mind being
positive and visualizing because I saw
it affect my pitching I saw it affect my
schoolwork I saw it affect my my
confidence I got everything out of out
of baseball Arizona State that I wanted
and it's the and I and I apply those
rules today like at the Comedy Store
playing Division one sports was a big
thing and I happen to go to Arizona
State where we have a lot of players in
the major leagues so I and we had access
to professional baseball coaches there
and that's where I learned the
visualization and then I see it around
when I hung out with the baseball teams
the Yankees the Dodgers and the Cubs and
there's something to it so I I'm not
trying to figure it out still but I know
it's something they're you know and I
can apply it to myself a lot of the time
you know it's easy to say but and you
know that's why I wouldn't mind being
around in baseball CNN did the thing
that bothered the [ __ ] out of me it
bothered the [ __ ] out of me because I
felt that a game excuse it had it they
had a docu-series called the dark side
economy the dark side of comedy oh one
thing Thomas and they discussed Rommel
Williams and the suicides and now yeah
and the drugs tennyson's and all this
[ __ ] and I agree with a lot of part of
it but I recently dealt with some [ __ ] I
don't know what it was I don't know what
it was it started like in March and it
went on until maybe the second week of
July after I shot the Netflix special it
wasn't pressure it was just as doubt
this dis this form of depression
I came over me you know it affected my
stomach and it was just really weird
that I found out from reading the old
journals mm-hmm I don't love to go three
weeks ago I go let me go back and see
what I was writing in March yeah and one
thing about depression is depression is
a [ __ ] if you let him it
yeah okay so how do you let depression
in from getting into your mind and not
getting sunlight not having contact and
I know all about it because like I'm
telling you guys I [ __ ] hate driving
I [ __ ] hate it but those weeks I'm in
town all week I thought to go on the
road sometimes I schedule something for
Thursday mm-hmm that's out of my
character and the whole week I'd read it
but while I'm driving in the 405 and
bumper-to-bumper traffic oh thank God I
got out of the valley like thank God I
thank [ __ ] god like enough is enough
that's the other reason why I call for
spots at the store makes me get out of
the valley yeah we go over the hill
every night every night you know I know
I can't do it every night but guys I
suffer from the same thing you guys
suffer
I learned about it 20 years ago
cuz I could thirty years ago I could
stay in they could put me on a [ __ ]
island that's my dream guys that's my
dream that my daughter grows up my wife
tells me she's gonna go and live in
[ __ ] New York and I [ __ ] go you
know what there's an island for 60 G's
[ __ ] the Navy drop bombs there 20
years ago and this [ __ ] nuclear
reactive I've got a little chip of the
aisle and get some chicken cutlets you
can imagine I'm the type of guy that
could be alone with that with music
marijuana I swear to died drums
I like throws weights weighing a
punching bag TV and internet internet
review will you podcast and para no no
no no no lock myself in oh I could be
one of those guys that I could stay in I
can eat the same [ __ ] every day
I could either more two down or salami
and American cheese sandwich every day
Oh protein shakes I can live on one
every day I'm a [ __ ] creature of
habit
so hum the times I scare myself with
that [ __ ]
I scare myself with that [ __ ] that's why
I forced myself to get the [ __ ] out I
forced I went through that cocaine
morning [ __ ] well you don't want to
leave the house because the cops are
watching you and all that yeah no no no
no no ever since I stopped that I forced
myself out because even I always knew
that that was the dark side accompany
the dark side of comedy is getting into
your mind but it's not the dark side
economy it's a dark side of life yeah
it's a duck Sun life it's not the dark
side economy if you let depression end
so as soon as you start feeling that
[ __ ] or that stuff that that gets you
all on the boat that's it you're out of
it oh don't smoke a joint go for a walk
go go for a walk go book a gig called
awful silly goat office online I'm not
talking about somebody that you pay I'm
talking about go talk to a friend a
friend somewhere Starbucks was there
with them sees you just forcing yourself
you know I do a stupid joke about the
universe it's very true you get back
will you put in yes
you know you'll only go to a kickboxing
class there's eight people in there
you're gonna jive one of those people
that one hour of you talking to those
other people to get you on the end your
phones in the car your mother's fine the
other person you gotta worry about is
your mother and your father everything
else is [ __ ] what a brother's ain't
gonna call you while you're in
kickboxing class nobody's gonna call you
while you're in kickboxing class this
times I go to like a jitsu class
mumbling halt when I get in the car
though be eight missed message now you
ain't got nothing nobody called you
nobody's gonna call you but just the
thought of getting away from the phone
yeah just that other thing just forcing
you away from that thought one hour it's
in the car and if it melts let it
[ __ ] melt I got insurance I'm gonna
do but just getting away from all I said
all this is lately is we have too much
[ __ ] information why do you think
comedy so big right now why do you think
I'm telling you to do a show on the
daytime
because man I wouldn't [ __ ] say this
if I didn't believe in it
five years ago I would not believe this
statement okay
people need company they do work we're
telling the truth people love it that
that's they love it that's why
well especially the we're on the front
lines at the Comedy Store
we're here in Hollywood and I feel like
if you have Harry scopes you're [ __ ]
just cat watching you interact with the
donut Korean let's say you did let's say
you went to the same cold water Aruba
side next to the dry cleaners there's a
problem of God you place this is Chinese
donut in there there's a donut in yeah
in the corner I know there's a Mexican
joint there yeah it's a hi frozen ice
shaved ice shaved ice those people real
Korean in there I went in there one mate
to get a bagel I asked him for like a
[ __ ] and this guy tried to sell me
like look at that Korean is ruthless
he's like putting on cut pumpkin bang go
listen oh you don't put logs on bumpkin
bagel I'm from there yeah I'm saying you
don't give a [ __ ] I have I have no onion
but I have there and blueberry blueberry
good for you oh good for you
you going in torch that every day on
candle for three minutes
that's a series for four minutes a day
people will pay a dollar to see you
going on a doughnut place and ask that
[ __ ] get me cinnamon doughnuts
run from there but I I know every day
you open up and say please that guy
every day for like I would if I knew
that that China guy would get pissed off
I walk in there every day knowing that
he didn't have a doughnut and then I
send them people in this like that's the
best reason so you torture people to
keep your brains are people just like
entertain like you like you like just
doing it to like socialize with a few
patreon oh my god you have no idea how
much fun you can have on the infinite
today if I had the time and the energy I
just want the yum-yum every day yum yum
minute just going in torture them how
many calories in the
and then like looking at you like you
know another language you going every
day and he asked a different Kelly you
never get a doughnut but but that's the
thing now today Hooten free donuts you
you have almost like no reason to be not
saying no reason to be depressed but
there's so many outlets before like what
if you're staying home you were sick
what he had like ten channels on TV and
that's it now you've got so many yes
there's a lot of drawbacks to the
internet and social media and all that
but it is there are a lot of positives
associated with it you just got to be
able to maintain it and also know that
it can be used for some good well I mean
times have changed I don't know but you
guys are hotels every week pretty much
whenever I go to a hotel
I used to love I would have TV on or
watch SportsCenter of this than that I
don't I know I'll be in a hotel room for
a weekend and not turn it on see I want
myself to leave the hotel room every two
hours smoke a joint that's why I bring
extra weed I smoke a joint I get the gym
I forced myself to leave the room every
two hours and I forced myself to leave
the hotel room for a patch I forced
myself on Saturday to go to lunch with
somebody you know somebody from the club
the club owner I do little things but
just enough to scratch that edge I can't
go to a baseball game for three innings
seven innings you know I do enough just
to scratch that edge so when you go to
town you'll schedule appointments with
people to keep that human contact going
right I'll schedule a Muay Thai class
well know what the jersey is we have to
get private jiu-jitsu class and Jersey
on Friday you know I went to the gym on
Saturday I forced my I have to force
myself because if not I will sit in
front of that iPad I don't watch sick I
you know what I love about the road what
do you long don't why I go on the road
to watch your iPad no it's not to make
money I love to meet different people
make people laugh I go on the road for
Friday night that's your night that's my
to go do a great show make them laugh
and meet people memories put out good
energy and no I don't have to do [ __ ] on
Saturday morning and you like that that
means I could go back and anything goes
on Friday night mm-hmm okay that means
that if you come up to me and give me
two vicodins I might go back to the room
and pop one put on a pot of coffee get a
notebook out and I watch I swear to god
I got no reason to lie to the audience i
watch five episodes of sons of anarchy
Jesus Lee how much do I yell at you for
watching TV a lot yet on Friday nights
when I'm on the room yeah that's me
that's my gift for leaving my family I
get a table I put my feet up with a
pillow to elevate above my heart because
I just fell on stage with two hours yeah
and I just sit there I can't bring a
vapor pen
I bring nicotine gum hmm sometimes I
bring a bag of Doritos or up to my room
and sometimes I eat it sometimes I leave
it for the maid I get coffee going and
coffee after the show in my room it's my
night to do whatever the [ __ ] I want on
Friday night after a show and I can't
wait to get back to the hotel sometimes
somebody will give me a pill or
something and I'll hold it for when I go
on the road to drop it that night while
I'm in the hotel I'm frying that like if
you give me two vicodin to hold on to
them
and I know that when I go to Portland
Friday night after the show I'll pop two
vitamins and go home I'll scratch and
I'll watch narcos and I watch four
episodes and narcos and not blink an eye
I could do that that to me is fun
because I know I'm gonna get up at 8:00
I'm still gonna go for breakfast and I'm
gonna go back to my room and sleep
another three hours
I'm still gonna get up early and still
gonna go to breakfast I still forced
myself off to breakfast walk down stairs
it sucks but I make myself do it just
even talk to the waitress whooping hey
that was a good show us and I thank you
then you go back to your room
sleep for three hours get up Oh
watching our ghost right I'm out come
back to put that to more I was writing
out one and a half I was writing out out
go roll the joint smoke a half a joint
hided behind a building come back so I
do you yeah I don't walk into the hotel
with that you abandoned the whole room
snows I get the thing I put a rock on
top of it when I come back two hours
later and I get ice take the rock off it
and they smoke the other half and how do
you stay disciplined on all of this is
is this what makes you happy makes the
shows better you fishes and it makes the
show better this is what makes me better
this is we are creatures of whatever you
know we and we have to force ourselves
and I didn't know this you have to force
yourself sometimes too how do you
comfort zone comfort zone is a big
[ __ ] word man mm-hmm
that's an ugly [ __ ] word and once you
feel yourself in that comfort zone get
in the [ __ ] car get out of the
comfort zone yeah yeah get out it was
pretty funny lead to the show this week
and it was you know I fell in love with
Brody
I don't know 19 years ago on a bar in
Gig Harbor I'll never forget and I'll
never forget what he said how he said in
the pause that he said it that's when I
knew Brody was real you know he was on
stage yeah and I told this on there ya
know he's the yelling screaming and in
the middle of it II turned around and
there was a bunch of photographs on the
wall he's up on stage yelling and
screaming they just stopped me was how
come there's no Jews upon a wall make
somebody come here that better be Jews
on the wall I'll never come to gang
harbor again I'm in the back with Josh
wolf
he's a kid I'm howling I fell in love we
you know gig harbor yep that gate was a
gig of death yep
Ross of Arizona's bridge it was home it
wasn't no [ __ ] evening at the pop see
them saying no so yeah and I had Lee
goes down the head he Bravo's 15th
reunion they throw this port back
on stage while the UFC's on he's up
there in the Korean zombie gets knocked
out and poor leaves up there with his a
material come on in front of the screen
thinking these aren't cold in somebody
came up to me nine by the way we're at
the tenth planet party we feel so bad
fully he want this I swear to God I
swear to God they were like tough spot
who the [ __ ] did that there I survived I
didn't I did my stuff but it's weird he
is he called his friend Eric gay Eric my
buddy Eric Koston and Eric bought him a
beer because he was so depressed he you
know he felt it and I explained them
last night I know I've been doing comedy
27 years I hope it's wrong can help them
for dice I threw all these games I'm
gonna tell you something half of your
career is those rooms you know where you
get there and listen and the Seattle
Mariners are in the playoffs and it's
the seventh inning and it's just a those
tougher are the eggs and you feel like
boom boom we wanna watch the game put
the game on well they gotta do comedy
and also the owner gets into an argument
they do comedy here we don't give a [ __ ]
about town they're right put the game on
but take the volume off oh yeah that's
it you know and you're up there on stage
dying a slow death thinking about career
choices you just want to zip recruiter
you looked you know it's it's [ __ ]
hard but then you do a guest spot at
them at the underground and see I don't
know them and that makes all that go
away because your strength isn't from
going on staging the Seattle underground
your strength from going onstage at
those places the hell get where they're
not a youth hostels yeah well they're
not there to see you
they'll be out the power I'm gonna get a
grand gig harbor sucked and the chubby
Jew wants to go on stage and do comedy
well I got this chick buddy here yeah I
got this chick right here and and some
[ __ ] Jew and a [ __ ] fat Cuban I'm
gonna go up on stage and try to be funny
people hate that [ __ ] especially when
it's unexpected it's weird because I
didn't I didn't unexpected one earlier
that week and I went fine I went pretty
well but then I was I did a show on
Thursday
replace but it went okay would but I was
talking to Jerry Rocha and the guy who
runs the show Justin and he was saying
Oh bear burger yeah yeah that's a good
room it was fun I've done it twice but
they were saying that they they did a
show with someone who didn't get booed
offstage got talked offstage and that's
pretty much I got I had a section of the
crowd listening but they what they were
saying was it's not that they didn't
like them until they were just
indifferent they weren't like the people
that crabbers is talking amongst
themselves or lathered the comment got
offstage well in those rooms just way
you learn presence yep
you learn how to fake the funk you learn
how to it's a weird thing to describe
you have to learn how to overtake them
without overtaking because if not you're
gonna bottle throw that you [ __ ] that
that's the reality of it yeah you know
I've seen it and I've heard about it you
know I was in a bar one night where they
were flipping bottle caps at the cops is
like you know when you and they got like
a red light on them and you can see the
bottle caps wizard and you can see the
comics like ducking from time that that
still happens no I don't you know I we I
haven't heard about it yeah but there's
got to be a [ __ ] country bar somewhere
or some [ __ ] crazy bar somethin that
they still you know throwing things at
people you know when we used to do
Moscow I know mm-hmm they would send you
25 shots oh yeah after Keela with with
Tabasco sauce Jesus and you had to do oh
my god they boo you off the stage
holy [ __ ] and you had a half hour and
that the trick was to kill the feature
and to just make the headline and going
to [ __ ] convulsions that's what they
wanted to do they wanted to do it they
didn't care about the condom the first
time you did a shot of tequila what you
weren't on stage five minutes and then
we're giving you a prayer what's called
prairie fire or a prairie dog oh my god
they would give you see what it's called
tequila and Tabasco
delete Bellingham no no no mas Glasgow
yeah close to a local state
yeah Washington Idaho State University
yeah the Vandals because that's the
college that drew blood so winter
prairie fire for every denial let me
tell you something Li think about going
on stage okay
oh my god you're opening up for time
additionally don't see over at this
hotel and it's all college students 200
college students and you go up on stage
and five minutes into your attic the
wait just comes up to you with a shot
you can't tell what thing they know I'm
not pregnant the key litter as soon as
you turn down that shot it's gonna be a
25 and you can't get off because you
won't get paid you can't get off cuz you
won't get paid so you take on a time the
club hold isn't saying you only did 21
but I gotta call the book or and see
what to do alright so now you look like
the [ __ ] jerk-off so you have to
either drink that shot and take what
comes with because they're not gonna pay
that and your material is not worthy of
anything just take the shots and talk
about grande drunk with them that's what
your 30 minutes is gonna be about that's
what these Road gigs are like Moscow I
that hold 10 [ __ ] times and after the
third time I got it sorry Charlie it's
not gonna be any different first two
times I just bombed I drank them the
third time I puked in the sink I never
forget that I puked in the st. Jesus and
then every time after I just brought
cocaine with me and I didn't get sick
anymore but one time I had the bed spins
yeah I don't want that it's [ __ ] bad
and there were tent out the big wall in
the Missoula Montana was like that there
was 20 bars that dog as soon as you went
on stage give him a shot of whiskey get
another shot of whiskey and you better
drink them god forbid you had to drive
to another gig that night there's no
there's no jury you don't even think
about it it's over you're sleeping in
the car and you're gonna [ __ ] drive 90
the whole morning well I was thinking
about this when you when you told me
that Brody was coming in I like Yugi
and Brody are probably two of the most
comfortable people on stay like I feel
like you feel comfortable on stage
Camby yeah and like it blows my mind
that you Brody will go on at the in the
main room and do like the drumming like
it's I just did the main room for my
first time ever and I got there like an
hour early right and was petrified like
how we have you always been that
comfortable in order to take years to
get that sort of like that's a level of
comfort that most people don't have um
it took a long time but you know once I
went for it once you'd like take that
milk and you pour it into that cereal
you like got to go for it so I gotta be
honest you had it than that I'm a thing
like that you did that you had that
already so yeah I've already had that I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] my pants
I don't give a [ __ ] attitude I could
tell you were [ __ ] in path but you
were taking chances taking chances but
we were young comics yeah in 95 I had
been doing comedy for four years on
paper but two years come on [ __ ]
yeah you want to do this about two and a
half years come on [ __ ]
and then they featured me for lorry kill
Martin and I didn't go back to bald I
was like I found the whole writing about
when I first found my real niche like I
was just going up then trying to tell
jokes and finding yourself and then one
Monday I got back with the stripper she
invited me to a house we had tremendous
sex I looked her in the ass came to my
home I can think Thanks she went we went
grocery shopping I had a hundred and
seventy father house to my name
groceries were a hundred and forty as
she looked at me and I paid four hundred
forty dollars worth of groceries at
thirty five miles and went back to a
house she made me turkey burgers with
mushrooms and onions with something on
the side of salad it was 6:30 my clothes
were there I was in a stay we were back
together and she
talking about some guys [ __ ] [ __ ] and
we got into an argument and I'll never
forget I said can I at least get half
the money from the groceries she goes
[ __ ] you
last time I paid for groceries so here I
am at the underground with my luggage
behind the counter everything I owned
dirty final hauls in my pocket nowhere
to sleep and I went up down to Monday
night and I said two or three jokes Lee
and I just went into this for years I
had that tape I gave it to Joe Rogan it
was one of the first times that Joe Diaz
came out that was when a friend he came
out and went right back in like he got
scared when I saw it on tape it
petrified me
I went up there and said exactly it
would like I went up then tried to be
cute and all of a sudden I go who the
[ __ ] my kid I want to kill this
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I just went on a rant
destroyed that room you know and I
forget the bit I got from it like I got
a joke from it being a stripper everyone
loved everything was going great then I
ran out of money
something like stupid but I just ran
with it and then I went into the [ __ ]
ball and chain something and then I
wanted to why and this is when o j was
hot like that yeah
95 over going into wide now I know why
he killed that [ __ ]
and people like ah but that was the
first time that I had done copy it took
me four years to really found my voice
and then I've said that's never gonna
happen again like I was so scared of
that guy coming out they took five years
for that guy to come out again so you
have it it just never the diet the day
it comes out on the way home you're like
oh what the [ __ ] happened today so you
know you have it you can go into that
gear you can go to that spot so you yeah
I was at the comedy underground that's
on a Monday night
that was the open ye night has a thick
beige sweater on would like stripe on
I'll never forget that I'll never forget
somebody saying hey
I taped that set and me looking I'm
going no you didn't and they like yeah
I'll have a few at the end of the week
nice somebody taped that set for me and
I popped it in and tears rolled down yes
like I was like oh my god I can't was
that person that Club was the Seattle
was just a great spot for me to start
and that's who you first got on stage
that was pretty much yeah I mean when I
moved back here I graduated college
Arizona State never did anything other
than an acting class then I came back
here in summer of 93 and it took a
workshop at UCLA with Pauly Shores
sister knowing that the Comedy Store
sponsored it so it was a way for me to
get into the comedy store I knew that it
could it was a way to possibly get seen
so did the workshop and then every
Wednesday I Drive by the Comedy Store
one day maybe I'll be in there and then
I did my graduating workshop there in
the original room was packed I did well
people giving business cards I felt like
it was a comedian then I did one open
mic out in Chatsworth like next night
and it was a typical open mic which was
like a not a wake up call but I didn't
want to go through that being that I'm
from the valley I just got done playing
baseball is gonna be hard for me to have
somebody probably not from the valley
running the show giving me like a kid
you know whatever you know yeah well
yeah I knew the open I just didn't want
I did one open mic to know it wasn't for
me and I went back to UCLA and I took
the business a comedy class I want to
learn all about comedy and then the guy
said if you want to do stand-up you got
to get out of it Los Angeles that's what
he told me I taught the class do you
Danny Robinson a PA no [ __ ] yeah
do you still see him from time to time
time to time time to time he says all of
it yeah yeah yeah big guy he represents
Tiffany Haddish oh he does yeah there
you go well he taught the workshop and
he said it's good to get away and then I
looked into going either back to Phoenix
where I had friends but no real feel for
support of art I didn't feel that vibe
when I went to school
but my aunts and uncles lived up in
Seattle and this has come up just come
up to Seattle they support the Arts up
here and then they had the Northridge
earthquake in 94 I was working at Macy's
Bullock's over there Topanga
promenade mall I got in the earthquake
happened got in the car and left and
drove up to Seattle stayed with my
family on out in Bellevue area and then
I just jumped into doing the open mics
at the comedy underground has jumped
into it mean people then I got a job at
the comedy underground learning all I
just want to learn everything about come
but I do it they come in just sat people
you know on Fridays and Saturdays clay
with you know was the gent ran it you
know with the long hair I still talk to
Lou fo really isn't like in Asia or
something he's an Asian yeah he taught
me all about clay Jones yeah clay job he
was an interesting guy and he taught me
all about how the club ran and all the
stories behind it and I just learned
about how to seed a room run a room see
a 33 person non showcase show I learned
about comedy there in Seattle and
luckily there's some great comedians and
there was just you know coffee shops
that's where I learned to write I
learned to drink coffee in Seattle I
just the the the environment up there
was really conducive to being to being
an artist and then we had the cable
access me and Tina we jumped on that we
did that and it was just a big it was a
great community up in Seattle where I
found my voice and then after three
years because I started up there I could
tell like I was only getting maybe guest
spots but I was itching to get out I was
itching I made kind of like found my
voice and wanted to do more and then you
told me Joey you said broke you got to
go to New York and then I went to New
York and that's where I really like
broke out and found my voice just
talking and walking getting off the
subway the l-train and walking the Lower
East Side with my headphones on and
visualize and feeling like yeah I'm cool
okay like give him myself that
confidence because I had some based off
the cable access show and mostly that
because I wasn't really getting great
spots at the comedy underground I mean
maybe a guest I wasn't their guy and I
I understood but when I went to New York
I felt that energy and I really honed my
voice doing the Lower East Side shows
and then I barked at the Comedy Cellar
but I was so because I thought it would
lead to get in a spot but but I was
intimidated by SD so I never really
asked her how to get on I was
intimidated but I saw the Comedy Cellar
bar come in so I knew Dave Attell Judah
Gaffigan Todd Barry Maher and I saw how
that room was run but still wasn't doing
it but New York is where you know I
started doing shows though some
alternative shows with Todd bear in
Maher and Dave Chappelle and I was
holding my own I just felt like I can
come back home to Los Angeles and I have
a marketable skill and my friends were
coming out here that I met in New York
or working for show so when I got here
in 2000 I had a place to stay at a car I
knew my way around and then boom I got a
spot on CBS late-night Late Late Show at
Kilbourne I did a premium blend and then
I got best damn sports show and then the
rest is history so if you want to say
that but I kind of like New York is
where I really like I honed it and as a
kid growing up here in the valley I was
just I was just I wanted to go to New
York City I wanted that gritty
skyscraper energy and that's what it
gave them you told me to go there and
that's where I like just started talking
like that's why I did surf reality
because they weren't into jokes it was
like talking so I talked about what was
on my mind getting mad about just New
York stuff or what have you so I did
that and then warm up was helped me
professionally like being around
celebrities or whatever and then just
doing shows and then going for it it's
like this is the major leagues now once
you're here in LA to have thoughts like
I'm not confident what are they gonna
think and I don't have that it's like I
can't this is it so I feel like I've
done pretty good in terms of like I have
a lot of like oh my resume is wide and
vast I just haven't really capitalized
on one thing and have done that whatever
that one thing may be well I gotta tell
you something
helm was a litera a couple minutes ago
religion cial because you know I had
this discussion with Duncan on his
podcast how I would love to tell you
there's not a god I would love to tell
people that there's not a god or a
higher force or a higher power but Mika
will the CEO was pivotal point in my
life like pivotal like looking back and
even though I got arrested six times
right you know it was the pivotal point
in my life like it taught me it took me
completely out of my comfort zone
I still remember going to the
underground I got into town at 1:00 in
the morning on Friday night slept got up
in 931 and got eggs and took a bus down
to a County underground mm-hmm and just
looked in there there was leaving it was
Swami's yeah
Swami's upstairs lubbers downstairs and
all I wanted to do was to figure out how
to get a spot and that was there the bar
was closed I'm looking through the
[ __ ] glass and my heart's pumping
does I met the [ __ ] comedy
underground and then I went back Sunday
and they told me to come back on Monday
and I that was the happiest day of my
life like that [ __ ] Sunday when they
said come back on Monday and sign up for
the open mic and I signed up the guy was
great to me and I gave my drop to them
records and then I said yeah we'll put
you up and I was like I do not believe
this summit the comedy on the ground I
can't do not believe this and then a kid
walked in with a Boston Red Sox hat on
backwards I know who that one is it was
Josh wolf everything um just latched on
don't my said you got it you're from the
east coast yeah you gotta film me and
I'm what's going on here I came on too
heavy to Josh I'm a man being like kind
of intimidated yeah I called him every
day for a week what the [ __ ] you know
call me back you know but I was just so
ready and then Karl woman Haven I will
assistant manager I will all be it's
like uh-huh
I'll be in that then for the rest of my
life I can never say no to him if he
calls me for something because that year
and a half with him was an education you
know that I was not gonna get in Denver
I was not getting that comedy education
in Denver Seattle new comedy the arts
they there's a reason there's a reason
why all those companies are up there the
contest took me to a different level
yep just doing the contest over those
coming in like six to seventh took me to
a different level and then being there
like being the feature at every six
weeks every six weeks I was a feature
mm-hmm you know I knew how to manipulate
John Fox
I knew out a minute be like giggles I
knew how to you know get Bellingham I
had a mom rotation on Monday I would fax
Pat Wolfson I would fax Donna Reed in
Yellin I would fax our berto who booked
the music box
I remember downtown you know in those
days Monday at 9:00 I was already on the
corner I didn't have a fax machine
giving them a quarter of fax a cover
sheet and a [ __ ] schedule fake fake
schedule completely fake bogus you know
thank God a lot of comedy clubs didn't
have web pages in those days right but I
wouldn't I like make up [ __ ] dates
like don't give me this like let's say
this week here if I was home I would say
I'm in Caroline's in New York I would
just flat-out lie on the resume and then
leave three weeks open so they could see
I was open and hopefully they'd give me
a Thursday at the music box or sad
Alberto booked two things that Wilson
had like four things
Donna Reed had like eight thing Ron
Reed's wife well she's a manager ozzie
Manor she was a manager but she Laura
Laura Krakow
rest in peace that [ __ ] had to yeah
Josh she had Josh but that [ __ ] had 15
rules in those days she had 15 to 20
rooms here those two Mexican rooms that
one room up in
and yeah she had rooms Jack see she
didn't really book me I wasn't booked me
but I got back at her I would call her
and ask her for guest spots like the
field of [ __ ] is tightening up the
whole vault because she hated me with
every piece of her art she hated me all
the way down to those but I would call
three times a week ago I'd done whatever
wasn't him was it Don the Laura Laura I
don't miss crock the Joey Diaz I could
hear her go I'm gonna go down to your
club tonight
don't guess brother's not okay with you
she would not pay me she never paid me
and done but to today I thank her
because her hatred made me a better
comic there you go I proved myself to
her that I was better than she was
she might have hated me but I did a free
spot in her rooms three nights a week
and the club all does you say why don't
you work here because she won't book I
mean Seattle was like that you know it's
like they're a if you're a big big guy
you know an Italian guy Seattle and
Italy it's like ditalion Stu different
danger well you know the thing about me
I learned to get early on the thing I
learned early on was that and this was a
no-brainer I think there was a guy named
there was a magician who worked the
Tribble run and he came in on a Tuesday
and he was a sweetheart of a guy and I
had him sleep over this is my first week
at cop the first year at comedy at this
point I was probably doing comedy nine
months and I let him sleep out in my
house I was divorced and I had two
bedrooms and the triple runs in those
days when Tuesday night Boulder
Wednesday night year off so a feature
act will pick up $50 cash I'd have to
pay $40 for a hotel room cuz you were
off write you off so that means you had
us pay for your own hotel Wednesday
night then Thursday was Craig Friday was
gonna sin and Saturday was [ __ ] the
edge of hell Telluride these were hell
these were tough gigs is that the devil
run was a big week Kraig Kahler
was the only room that in the thing had
said this room gets active the stage was
30 feet away and there was glass they
would throw [ __ ]
oh really and they said if something
happens if go to your room lock yourself
in and call them neither I mean I'm the
[ __ ] thing it said would just make
you laugh like underneath the room
that's in question this room gets active
so act what I would do in those days
will let if the headliner or the feature
were cool I give him my number said call
me when you check out you got a
consciously upon tomorrow and some of
those guys at Doug Stanhope the guy that
took cranny Prince's place and she's
going to man I had a couple guys there
but one guy stayed over that wasn't the
funniest guy in the world but he was a
magician comic and he was kind of a nice
guy mm-hmm he gave me a list of Booker's
you know like those guys I have those
sheets yeah he went through the printing
place and he made like 20 sheets of
bookings but he told me something I said
to him do you think I should go to New
York and he goes why would you want to
do that there's a thousand years in New
York you know there's a thousand years
in Boston because you gotta find the
market where there's nobody else like
you can't get shot you could you could
be unique and people why that's why when
the opportunity for Seattle came up I
was like I'm going yeah Seattle it's uh
this is the same thing I told you
mm-hmm and it also told this to Mitch
Hedberg oh the reason why I told you
guys this is because they had a thousand
you are here there's a thousand goofy
white guys they don't have that New York
now they do now they got everything in
there right but about 20 years ago 20
years ago there was a lot of guys like
me nobody talked to the audience which
is a bad habit that you pick up in New
York he talked to the audience
so the did boat the coasts were
different yeah so I talked the Hedberg
God rest his soul and I told him there's
nobody would like you in New York
he New York went to New York because
there's nobody like
you there that's where you really get
loved whether people like you it's no
luck I knew when I saw you that there
wasn't nobody like you in New York at
that time yeah now there's a thousand
guys trying to Rory Stevens they don't
work you follow me and then they become
themselves yeah you know when we all
start we start being somebody else then
we become ourselves we evolved into
ourselves I just think like comedians
you I try to send them to New York City
try and spend some time there go there I
I you know move there I became I lived
there for three years I wasn't going
back and forth I was living there and I
got to experience that New York
lifestyle taking the subway and being
you know you could did it wasn't like
who you were was what you were you know
people were like you didn't you could
the matter what you look like New York
nobody cared
whereas LA I grew up here in LA I went
to school in Arizona it wasn't it was
not it's completely different from New
York just New York just really opened my
gave me that confidence if you can make
it in New York you can make it anywhere
that's what they say and I just recently
went back to New York last month and I
felt that energy again just walking
around that city and you know getting
out of Los Angeles here getting out of
the valley just getting getting into
that and getting off the internet
getting out of your head walk in that
city and you're feeling you walk in you
can it inspires you and and and you
start saying yourself I don't need to
have these meds Ness I don't need to
have all these things and overthink it
you jump in and you got a sink or swim
there it's good for you
I think everybody I think most comedians
should strive to live if they can
therefore I didn't I mean aside the ten
month stint then the beginning and it
woke me the [ __ ] up I didn't let me know
who the [ __ ] I was what I wanted and
what I needed to do to
get to my goals like in that that's
that's why I went right back to Denver
with a firecracker on my ass and I went
to Denver I worked every night and I
took that work ethic up to Seattle and I
just did Seattle it was double of work
right so now I had double the payload
you know no matter what you do in life
you have to sacrifice man and you have
to get out of your comfort zone to get
to where you want to be whether you're
an artist or [ __ ] you know you're you
play the trumpet but you play the
trumpet in [ __ ] Louisiana not
Louisiana in Utah what's listen to a
trumpet Louisiana you gotta go to a jazz
bar in Minneapolis or a jazz bar New
Orleans or you know a jazz bar in LA you
know sometimes you gotta and then people
can't make that step so they never
fulfill what the [ __ ] they wanted to do
you know I mean when you came in tonight
and you said you got off those meds I
gotta tell you something brownie I'm
proud of you thank you
I'm proud of it and I'm proud that you
know like you said well whatever I'm
calmed and one thing about me is man I
put myself in the worst case in there
and they told you I said you know and it
was a joke and we laughed you know a
couple years ago you want to rub a room
looking smart imaginary flies you in a
rubber room saying help there's a fly
who's talking hide I I was combative
with the Filipino nurses at you know
they threatened me with the needle right
but I was all I go I don't need to be
here I go I made a mistake go look on
the internet I'm a good guy I kept
telling him like look me up but now that
was a crazy time but I was kind of like
to be honest I yeah I couldn't believe
that I was in the UCLA hospital
I made days to have you were there for
17 though they did they wouldn't let me
leave the one from three days just six
days to nine days and basically did you
make any meaningful relationships in
there did you meet anybody that you've
contacted and soon you know one girl
like attack me over like chocolate ice
cream
sign it was 17 days yeah who knew about
this at the time did your mom know my
mom I mean people knew I think because I
was tweeting about it I I think I just
needed to like dry out because I I went
off those meds cold turkey I made a
mistake I went to Ireland I went to
Montreal they told me to take a victory
lap I'm having fun I actually took a
little less because I wanted to I'd
always had wanted to
it's not maybe beyond the lexapro which
is common but I also knew that going to
Dublin and I was researched like okay if
you want to drink a beer maybe cut back
a little bit I cut back and then I got
sick in Montreal right after it was like
a two-week trip all together and then
they gave me a the z-pak and I had strep
throat and then they gave me the z-pak I
felt better and I said I feel great I
don't need these I don't think I need
the meds anymore I'm like through this
period and then but here's the thing I
was just I'm still alive with about 17
days that I did that I quote flow the
Cuckoo's Nest well you know what it was
like everything about this I wrote I
have my notes somewhere but I felt I
mean I lie we do a short film by u17
they stent and then you'll be brutally
honest like what you did share that
that's the secret right there if we
could recreate a play ping-pong I smoked
meth meth all cigarettes with methyl
Mendel menthol it's menthol
I'm listening to radio watch TV you talk
to me buddy we knew just um not really
but I had a lot of visitors a lot of
friends who came by Bozak came by Nick
Kroll Steve Rannazzisi I don't even know
you were in debt this is crazy this is
the yeah I had a Booker they were like
bringing people in you know we could
have got you in worked in and where were
you a UCLA right over the hospital there
Ronald Reagan I guess psychiatric ward
but I wasn't I because I've felt that
way before
well not necessarily I just know not to
go you just can't do it I want to the
trigger that time I think when I came
back
so I I what do you need to avoid to stay
off the meds and not back there what is
the battery pack it back at you through
all that sandflies talking to Chinese
people it's feast or famine oh yeah
torture Philip I don't know I mean I
should probably have some like a support
system with this but I'm being my own
advocate I know my body I'm mature I
know choices I'm not saying that I won't
ever go back on a medication we'll see
but so far I'm trying to implement a
life skill
you know like socializing booking
working being a being an adult and
taking supplements doing my comedy
believing in myself I'm just calmer if
my body feels better of this I'll say
that so for me to not go back I mean I
never had a problem before or after I
had a reaction to these medications is
what I because I was never headed like
this guys I was never gonna be like
something like that I went off um it was
just and I was agitated it's like I
attacked a guy at a start couple
Starbucks a 7-eleven I was like road
rage guy but I was just but I know
you're banned from this table cool no
comment no um I know here's what
happened I felt when I got back I think
my friend saw me and they were surprised
like Oh Brody you're not yourself but I
felt like okay I'm you know I feel
better I'm not the audience warm-up guy
I'm Brody now I got have to show on HBO
happening I have good things happening
so I came back confident and I think
people were a little like taken aback
that oh he's confident we're not used to
this guy because I did the TMZ show they
loved it I did it that day I did a
taping I did a show at UCB and I did
fine I was just out of my character they
weren't used to it and then when they
questioned me then I became defensive
and my my I became agitated so and this
was like a first time of it happening
and then you tie in the Twitter that's
the other thing I that outlet to go you
know to lash out but I was also
I mean I I did stuff on Twitter also you
know saying like FeO the Twitter thing
was what I had heard that you were
cracking on Twitter I did hear that I
heard something about a roof no roof no
no I was never I never I felt great with
nothing you were gonna jump with nothing
that you climbed or something no no no
climbing I didn't know clients I don't
know you on a zipline Woodley took it
down I don't [ __ ] know they did go on
Twitter and I was lashing out but part
of us cuz because I did TMZ and these
guy and I felt like I did a good job and
these guys are saying I'm out of my mind
fu I know what I'm doing and I just had
all this confidence and not being on the
medication to like hold me back I was I
was basically manic that's all I mean
not that's all but that's what was
happening to me and it was freaking
people out so they called the police as
opposed to maybe saying hey Brody maybe
we'll go to let's go to you know go to
Santa Barbara for a few days and chill
it could have been handled that way I
looking back on it to be honest with you
because I've learned since like you
could believe me if I take Red Bulls and
do something I know you I could like get
agitated I was just I was uh yeah I just
typical signs of stopping the meds Colt
ekiden that could have happened to
anybody so I don't feel like I have
that's something though that's in me
whether gonna happen I don't think so I
would hope not I don't know we'll see
how I deal with with stress that's why
podcasting that's why having a support
system you know I started doing the
periscopes after all this to check in
and be more you know and be more present
and walking making appointments
periscopes are brilliant that's
brilliant I didn't know you used it
they're in beautifully also I did that a
little bit after yeah like this was like
a year or two after but definitely like
walking became therapeutic like getting
out of the house I learned to get out
walk and go to the Starbucks people like
associate me with going to Starbucks
that's because I walk to it I made it
known like I'm known for being out
for you're forcing again you're doing
what we discussed early on you're
stopping the [ __ ] before he even
shows up yeah you're stopping depression
before even shows up you're stopping
your mind from going there before they
even take you there you know much as
always that's I've learned when your
mind is taking you there to take it
somewhere else
trust me took me 30 years I'm no
psychotherapist I just know if I wait if
I go to bed and I wake up of 3:00 in the
morning with something on my mind I did
that for years I'll go insane and pace
and then we'll nothing took a local town
and I wrote down when I was mad about go
smoke go to make a cheese come back and
read it you'll fall right to sleep but a
lot of this depression for me if I'm
susceptible to some of that if I am so
it's I think it's a lot of its career
fine it's like that sort of thing it's
not these are not irrational thoughts so
some of these thoughts about like money
or career I am I I can rectify them by
taking action so for me to go hey I'm
gonna I need a pill or I go need to talk
to somebody no you need to go book a
podcast you need to go show your face
you need to go for a walk you need to
sign up for a class so I'm implementing
you know those activities to stave it
off and I you know I get down on myself
I've always been someone who you all got
we all do I've always been that but I'll
say this like I'm lucky I'm grateful
that I have the that that I've made you
know I've I've been able to do comedy
and I can perform at The Comedy Store I
can go places because it's it's an
outlet it's it's not therapy it's
therapeutic and I know it helps other
people as well and I think today with it
being so negative out there and if I can
share some of my some of my philosophies
without jamming it down their throat but
baseball's fun I've been around
successful
baseball successful TV show successful
comedians podcasts I'm sharing that and
then the Comedy Store being the hottest
club and if you have your name on the
marquee and you're have a spot at the
Comedy Store that means something and I
know that and I try to share with people
how I might think you know like I'll
even joke like I got a you didn't laugh
at that joke well I get free Red Bull
you didn't laugh at that joke I parked
for I I park wherever I want so why
don't you do what I do it's kind of a
joke but it is a joke but I think that
yeah I'm lucky I'm lucky but I'm just
you know how lucky we are very lucky
very very lucky just the fact that we
were together in Seattle mm-hmm did you
ready people grab a pen and a piece of
paper 1997 even before I got there in 96
I got there 90 just for its 90 its 2018
so we've known each other we've been in
the struggle the 22 years mm-hmm
we've been apart for four of those years
you were in New York mm-hmm that's we're
very lucky we're very lucky there's a
lot of people that we were up there and
there was one line in that 16 list I'll
never forget you know listen man when
I'm in that [ __ ] hole folks home and
my memories gone and I'm dying I'm gonna
think of those Monday nights they were
great and very very special to me there
were your whole week that's what people
don't understand that's what sucks about
doing comedy in that way that you don't
have a home club and you don't get
pushed apart by your peers because in
Houston on Monday nights you had a show
up every Monday with a new five minutes
your peers forced you because it's not
you look that [ __ ] bad mm-hmm so you
know we had that we had that that every
Monday you had a show three minutes
you could shop with some of this shading
it last week but you better show up with
something to [ __ ] kill that was your
goal on Monday two minutes he only had
six minutes right yeah six eight into
the closet that's 15 oh no the open mic
you'd get six apiece
it was six five five six light at five
six because they were training you for
the Seattle Comedy Competition okay
remember Seattle Comicon this five six
the first week light at five you gotta
be off by six oh you got a point taken
away so they trained you for that to do
the open mic system so I mean just for
that alone if I don't wake up tomorrow
we still had the opportunity growing
together going fall I mean I got locked
up in jail for 30 days in Seattle you
got putting a loony bin down here for 17
days it's no different we all had our
[ __ ] shortcomings but what's
important is that we're still in LA
we're still doing smart was still
relevant and it goes back to those
Monday nights yeah if you go home
tonight smoking joint you really think
about what we learned on those Monday
nights just torch from Reno
Oh Oh taking her pills and even a pizza
and her nachos we would eat him nachos
burrito is the local [ __ ]
good nachos they're at a time around she
was up we'd build the bartender laughs
and then I still remember his girlfriend
and Clay's girlfriend nods Maryland
sitting there on the Monday night opened
by two chicks like this waitresses I
think the hot asian there was a hot
asian waitress on Monday nights yeah I
remember I was Bill's girlfriend and
then we go upstairs and that bartender
[ __ ] hated me but a hi Anthony
Anthony but I had a tab in there I still
remember go on upstairs and seen
Seahawks all the baseball team hours and
all the baseball teams it was uh and you
know what there was no ATM card there
was no car there was no HBO there was
Netflix I lived in an office a little
bit smaller than this one on the floor
with it with three or four thousands of
pillow a half a blanket and my clothes
next to me on the floor and those are
the happiest times my [ __ ] life going
down on a Monday night yeah and then we
leave there and go somewhere else who
had cages they have another open mic
come on oh yeah right I didn't I didn't
really do that white bar it was yeah
sound we'd go there and they had chicks
and cages that was always there and
while you're on staying while you're a
state that's always great you say it's
Alex and then we got the Tacoma contest
yeah we have a coma crossroads
crossroads she contacted me recently oh
really
- say hello she's still around so listen
man you know when you get a check now or
where something good happens I want you
to remember that you earned all this you
there's no reason to ever end up for me
what I did I got it something just left
lips but everything goes back to those
Monday night in Seattle so I'm thankful
I had that and I had that scene in
Denver before Seattle but nothing beats
my comedy a breath in those two years
those 18 months I didn't see how made my
mind become a comma and I'll never ever
ever forget that you were part of that
you thank you yeah just they were so
into the arts with the coffeehouse the
weather and the late-night diners and
just the characters in the scene and the
cable-access shows and they watched it
Seattle really supported that stuff you
couldn't do that in a Los Angeles or and
it was it was a big city but it was a
small city and it was you just knew
you're doing something right it was on
that and in Seattle you know it needed
the Gragas grunge was just dying out but
there's this something to let's think of
all those guys were there at that point
mitch hedberg
you myself Josh wolf Craig Gass all
those comedians they're still working
like they do the cruise ships they do
all the corporate stuff Seattle David
Crowe David Crowe my god
Hawaiian kid Kermit appear over the
happy Oh Vince founds way love still
around
yeah he lives in Santa Monica I don't
know if he's doing comedy anymore so I'm
on face I think you got a new hip do he
yeah it's talking about on Facebook but
there's just characters in Seattle that
you wouldn't get I would say like yeah
you said I may be a Denver you wouldn't
get or Phoenix or Dallas so when I think
about a lot is the cook at the end the
ground downstairs like a long hair I he
was if guys used all the most
interesting guys I haven't met we don't
have time to go into him now but what
was his name
I have to call Josh okay
yeah I remember I remember his face I
remember his long hair and the nights
that I couldn't make the bus back the
bell though ever Josh little view
Bellevue I would space stay with him
okay and I can't tell ya every time I
stayed with him it was a different
adventure first yeah first of all he had
no heat you live in the house two blocks
from the thing he had two broken windows
to air I remember it's snowing and you
know by the window there was like three
inches of snow turn to slinging I'm in a
corner with ten blankets on my Jaqueline
do you know I felt I I got so [ __ ]
high in his apartment one night that you
had to go take a [ __ ] cuz he lived in
the warehouse uh-huh you had to pull the
thing up in the elevator go upstairs and
there was three people on the floor but
one shower and one bathroom and that one
day I was walking towards the bathroom I
just remember this and I [ __ ] was
hung over and I was so [ __ ] up the
night before that before I went in the
shower I passed out and went through
this sheetrock there was an imprint of
me going through the [ __ ] sheetrock
till this day it's probably still me
just dipped over and broke the [ __ ]
wall but it was an imprint you can still
see my head where I went through the
sheetrock and he woke me up and they
threw me in the shower
Jesus Christ crazy times before social
media before all of this
technology was a it was a simpler time
it was it stopped to be him and that
meant a lot of information while I've
seen in the last three years I've seen I
feel a lot more people go crazy then
I've ever seen in my life are you tell
them on two hands and you think it you
think it has something to do with social
media that's one of the conduits for to
think that it's rolled around it's
everything that's going on social media
the way the news is portrayed the way
people are acting the political climate
doll I think that it's just people
losing their minds I see it every day
and it's sad it's sad but they I'm happy
you rough the mood thank you and I may
go back on but we're good now right now
we have bounced balance your Zack light
system with me thank you import system
with Josh wolf yep you have the calm
restore and that's the most important
thing man I'm happy you're still doing
your thing you're always welcome out of
the church Church of what's happening
and [ __ ] it keep doing what you're doing
if next time you go to if next time
god forbid I'll go visit oh you'll visit
okay we'll get you booked I'll smuggle
some mint to keep saying I don't wanna
cook something keep you going
I love you Brody Stephens thank you for
coming on the church brother Thank You
Joey
Thank You Lee I want to thank Brody
Stephens I want to thank my man Lisa and
I want to thank you guys I also wanna
[ __ ] salute the soldiers happy
Veterans Day populated thank you for
your duties and thank you for putting
your ass on the line for [ __ ] pieces
of [ __ ] like me but anyway talk this
cheap listen next Thursday went
Wednesday night I'm all sold out in
Irvine before Thanksgiving but what I
did was ahead in the second show Friday
night at 9:45 perfect it's Joey Diaz and
the church [ __ ] all-stars tremendous
lineup police I had will be there on the
drums it's gonna be great if you're not
doing none denied after Thanksgiving you
want to get out of the house 9:45
perfect you don't have to [ __ ] him to
drive in traffic or Nothing there's
gonna be like [ __ ] stealing
a couple jokes we got out of about 11:00
11:15 and everybody's happy you can make
the flea market I'm sad they're right
and don't forget Portland is sold out I
don't know what the [ __ ] did I hear
right beside that I love you
[ __ ] don't forget you know the
church we got sponsors and they're the
best sponsors in the world not I
wouldn't have them starting with blue
apron blue apron delivers farm-fresh
ingredients and step-by-step recipes to
your door we shoot chef design recipes
and we deliver fresh seasonal aspiring
ingredients that you could cook
incredible meals and as little as 20
minutes let boyfriend do the meal prep
for you
dinner and as little as 20 minutes who
could beat that every week at least
three recipes are built with your busy
schedule of mind where boy put has done
the meal prep for you prepared the
sauces spices and ingredients quick and
easy recipe options when insanely
delicious flavors perfectly proportioned
ingredients delivered right to your door
skip meal planning and get straight to
cooking with blue apron get rid of the
grocery list and let blue ape and do the
meal prep for you choose your recipes
based on your schedule let me tell you
what they got this week smoky chicken
and sweet potato baked with cheesy corn
bread biscuits do you know how to make
that no you know how ditalion sausage
pizza with roasted peppers and olive
oils my mommy I did how to make that
know you know beef broccoli and cumin
spice sauce
homestyle beef medallions with maple pan
sauce and hearty vegetable grain bowl
where you gonna get that who's gonna
teach you how to make that nobody blue
apron that's who
blue apron helps you get out of your
routine of cooking the same recipes with
chef design recipes and restaurant
quality meals so check out this week's
menu like I told you and get your first
three meals for free at free blue apron
calm slash Joey that's whipping calm
slash Joey get your first three meals
for free blue apron a better way to cook
number two listen I did it
I'm West African I got some Spanish
blood
I got some shiny blood I got everybody I
got some a little Russian Jew blood and
I'm very proud of that that's very nice
how did I find out 23andme 23andme is
named after the 23 chromosomes that make
up our DNA 23andme ancestry service
allows you to see how your DNA breaks
out across 150 regions worldwide trace
parts of your ancestry to a specific
group of individuals from a thousand
years ago can you imagine have to find
that way discover how Neanderthal DNA
you inherited opt in and connect with
DNA relatives and find other 23andme
customers who share your DNA and
successive ancestry I'm sorry you don't
know how many times I got an email and
you see all the people that you're
related to all over the country it's
mind-boggling it's mind-boggling
now the ancestry composition report
between three Emmys you can't explore
where your DNA is from out of 150
regions discover the origins of your
maternal your mother's and your father's
side ancestors how they moved around the
world over thousands of years you can
trace parts of your ancestry to a
specific group of individuals from a
thousand years ago did you know that
women can only trace their maternal
haplogroup this is because the paternal
haplogroup is traced to the Y chromosome
which women do not inherit this is the
stuff you learned with 23andme so so so
from today Tuesday till next Thursday
Thanksgiving 23andme and since the
service kids are $49 per kid this is it
this is your Christmas present for you
your girlfriend your boyfriend your wife
your husband your sister this is it you
get to listen to two kids $49 per kid
where you buy two or more that should be
percent off the regular price of $99
order your 23andme ancestry service fit
at 23andme calm
slash church that 23andme dot-com slash
church find out what you're made of I
also want to thank one of my favorite
people
world fishing Tom why cuz they're
keeping [ __ ] clean you understand me
and they're saving the environment why
because they're a portable bidet that
you install yourself in seven minutes
they start at $69 and let me tell you
something you don't know what it's like
to have a water creature up your little
ass it's not a wiping a nice proportions
and wash that muffle clean you eliminate
germs and hemorrhoids and [ __ ]
hemorrhoid juice let's say you got a
girlfriend her ass smells a little funky
this is a way of telling them their ass
smells funky without tummy you know I'm
saying you ever have to tell somebody
you're a smells like a billy goat but
you don't heard the balls cuz she sucks
a good dick or something like this is
the way to do it
Toshi calm right now I'm gonna give you
a 10% off code word muffler I'm sorry at
the beginning of the show I said Church
[ __ ] that the code word is muffler save
on toilet paper these portable bidet
start at $69 and you install them
yourself you understand me if you got
[ __ ] on you you want it to know you wipe
it off but no with the bidet taking my
[ __ ] my by the moment you turn the water
on
Wow you sit there when was the last time
somebody shot water up your [ __ ]
before Thanksgiving are you crazy or
what called atashi got time right now
pressing muffler at 10% off all right I
want to thank pushy
I want to tank to 23andme and I want to
thank blue apron for being the best
monsters in the world number two I want
to thank you [ __ ] that came out
to the shows in New York and number
three I want to thank all you
[ __ ] that watch the show and
support us over the years you're some
bad [ __ ] again Brody Stevens
Joey Diaz and my main man that
[ __ ] Lisa at I'll see your
mother [ __ ] this Thursday tip-top Magoo
ready to go
stay black kick this [ __ ] mealy